Hello the internet, my name's Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Something I quite like the look of, Dan,
in slow mo is bullets
coming out of a gun, hitting stuff.
Yeah, very fast though.
Very fast.
Plus, Gav's scared of guns.
Hate them.
So instead, I had to
buy a little air pistol.
Oh God, do you remember when
we did the assault rifle.
You were awful.
It was like this .
Leaning back, closing your eyes.
So, a little air pistol,
slightly safer option.
Yeah, we're gonna shoot
some deodorant sticks,
different colors.
Not sponsored by Old Spice.
No, you can't see the brand here.
Couldn't buy off-brand ones,
you had to go for Old Spice.
Oh, look all right, I was in a rush.
.
You may think why a stick of deodorant,
and I'll tell you.
They're sort of good at showing
an entrance and exit wound.
They're goopy but after
the damage is done,
they hold their form so you
see the flowering left there.
So, they're not as strong as flesh,
but we're also using an air pistol,
so, it's balancing out there.
It's really not a good test of anything
but it might look good.
Look, all right, don't justify it,
it might look good in
slow mo, let's do it.
We're gonna be using the v2511
insanely fast camera,
we'll start at 28,000 frames a second,
because once again,
if we filmed it on the Phantom Flex,
it would be a couple of blurs.
Yeah.
Couple of blurred frames.
I'm gonna get the blue, shoot through it.
Let's start with the blue.
Safety off.
Hit the fence.
Bloody hell.
All right, we'll have that come in
slightly off-set.
Straight through here, yeah?
Yeah, just don't shoot the lens hole.
I'll try not to.
Flippin' wicked.
If you've ever accidentally
shot through some deodorant,
what you can do is just
push this stick up enough
so that the bullet hole is gone,
and then you can just cut
with a knife the top part.
Now, that is a pro tip.
Also, aka, we only bought one,
and now we're screwed.
Yeah, so we've got two
shots and that's it.
Yeah, nothing goes to
waste on Slow Mo Guys.
We get everything--
High budget video, this one.
We get the maximum--
What's the shopping list for this video?
A deodorant.
Maybe in future, buy a few.
All right, all right.
Buy more than one.
I've got it, I've got it.
Very nicely, yeah, oh, deluxe.
Look at that.
Oh, it's like you'd never notice.
So, that last one was wicked,
so, I've lowered the resolution down,
we're now at 120,000 frames a second,
just close in on that exit wound.
Exactly the same?
Exactly the same.
Okay, I'm gonna place it down.
Oh, it's a bit tricky because
it's so top heavy now,
it's gonna fall over.
That's all right, as long
as it falls after the event.
We have to do it the other way,
we have to flop it.
Sun in that.
It's pretty ugly shooting
against direct sunlight but...
At these speeds.
Who gives a damn.
It's a must.
Here we go.
Oh, flippin' heck.
Destroyed the whole thing of it, look.
Absolutely chopped the top off there.
Made a perfect little canyon through that.
Oh yeah.
It must have sent some bits flying
'cause I saw it just--
Well, I got hit in the neck
with a little bit of it.
I hope you're all right.
My neck's gonna be
smelling like Terry Crews.
I met Terry once, yeah.
I saw him once.
You did?
In 2007, at the premiere of,
it was like Balls of Fire or something,
it was like a table tennis movie and it--
Why is it that individually,
we've both met Terry Crew
but nine years apart.
Well, I haven't met him,
I was like, okay Terry,
I just sort of saw him,
I was like, oh damn, it's Terry Crews.
Do you still have the
picture you took of him?
Yeah.
All right.
Okay, it's a tall order B,
but could you get it to go
in through the entire thing
from left to right,
but favor the front edge
so it's just barely in the front?
Who do you think I am, of course I can.
All right, I don't even
know why I doubted you.
You're ridiculous.
Sorry, B.
Nailed it.
.
Aw man, you just dug out the front,
Nailed it, look at that.
And it's good for another exit wound shot.
.
Actually looks like it's riffling,
not sure whether it's the sheen on the sun
or whether it's actually spinning.
Oh no, it's definitely
spinning, it's cool.
Even these little pistols have .
Is that true?
Yeah.
I guess that makes sense, why not, right?
Found a second blue one then?
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay, so I think for grand finale,
we'll line up all the ones we didn't use,
and that's what, six total?
Yes.
And try and shoot down
the line of all of them.
Okay, what do you think
is gonna happen though?
I think one of three things will happen.
It will blast through all of them.
Yeah.
It will get lodged in one of them.
Okay.
Or it will enter
and exit before it gets to the end.
So, it might exit in number
four or something like that.
How many do you think
it'll get through then
if it's gonna stop in one of them?
If it's gonna stop, I'd say the last one
'cause I'm pretty sure
it's gonna go through
every single one.
I think it's pretty warm today so--
It's a soft day.
It's quite soft.
All right, it's not the
best looking framing
'cause the table is on the piss
but all right, you know what,
I'm gonna correct it with the camera.
There you go.
Okay.
Ah, it hit me in the face, oh.
Oh.
What?
It's lodged.
Is it lodged?
It actually stopped?
Yeah, it only got through one, two, three,
it got through, it's in the fourth one.
You can see it, look.
.
Look at that.
Perfectly in the middle.
Wait, hold it up, hold it up to the light.
Hold it up to the sun.
Oh, you can fully see it in there.
Literally perfectly halfway through.
It's suspended.
Yeah.
I'm surprised .
That's incredible, isn't it?
It's amazing.
I might just keep that.
Yeah, that's a trophy.
Well then, one day you'll use it
and be like, ow, what the .
I've just got a ball bearing in my armpit.
Yeah, wow, we stopped a bullet,
well, we stopped an air pistol
bullet with just deodorant.
Well, you were right
with one of the options.
So, that must mean the third one
is the least damaged.
Well yeah, because it's come out perfectly
through the hole there.
I can't see through it but,
oh, hang on, I can see your nose.
Well.
There you go.
Can't really miss it.
No, but look at this though,
it absolutely tore
through these blue ones.
I think the blue ones are softer.
Well, they're also pretty wounded.
Yeah, they're pretty wounded.
But I think they're also
more susceptible to heat
'cause this one's much more solid
and then it couldn't even get through
the last green ones, so...
Very cool.
But you can trace the path of it
through the green ones.
You can hold this up here.
That's the path it took.
Yeah, very neat.
Lovely.
Yeah, I mean you can see what you meant
by the whole flesh wound thing.
Yeah.
It's the one with the--
Fully lodged in number four there.
It's cool, I love it.
Some very low resolution footage there
but it does show in more
detail what's happening.
Yeah, we needed the speed--
The speed detail, not resolution detail.
But basically, the camera's
great for making GIFs
because they're about that size.
Yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
subscribe to our second channel,
and buy some merch.
Buy some merch.
Buy some merchandise.
And we'll hopefully see
you in the next video.
Absolutely.
Absolument.
oh, fuck.
Fuck, ow.